President Trump added new tension to the
public impeachment hearings on Friday
which the White House dismissed is put
useless and inconsequential former UNM
but US ambassador to Ukraine Murray
Ivanovich testified Friday about a smear
campaign orchestrated by the president's
associates that led to her removal but
moments after her tests and when he
began the president weighed in attacking
her in real-time it's a development most
Republicans were not expecting Ben Tracy
is at the White House Thank You morning
good morning so the White House plan was
to insist that President Trump is too
busy being president to dignify even
watching these impeachment hearings
which he calls a sham but the president
himself dropped a bomb on that strategy
shortly after Friday's hearing began
former Ukraine ambassador Murray
Ivanovitch testified that she felt
threatened after reading an account of
president Trump's July 25th phone call
with ukrainian President Solinsky where
he called Jovanovic bad news and said
she was going to go through some things
what was your reaction when you heard
the President of the United States refer
to you as bad news shocked appalled
devastated that the President of the
United States would talk about any
ambassador like that to a foreign head
of state
Jovanovic detailed a smear campaign
against her led by Rudy Giuliani the
president's personal attorney who was
running a shadow foreign policy in
Ukraine I've been watching today for the
first time I started watching the White
House had claimed president Trump was
too busy to watch the hearing but about
an hour into ivanovich's testimony mr.
Trump launched a Twitter attack on her
everywhere maria ivanovitch went turned
bad the president tweeted with no
evidence it is a u.s. president's
absolute right to appoint ambassadors
and now the president real-time is
attacking you in an extraordinary moment
Committee Chairman Adam Schiff read the
tweet and asked for Jovanovic his
response I mean I can't speak to what
the president is trying to do but I
think the effect is to be intimidating
well I want to let you know ambassador
that some of us here take witness
intimidation very very serious
Democrats are now considering adding
witness intimidation to their articles
of impeachment and even some of the
president's allies admit mr. Trump hurt
himself with the tweet I don't think so
at all the president says he was just
speaking his mind I have the right to
speak I have freedom of speech just as
other people do republicans argue that
Jovanovic his testimony was irrelevant
because she was removed two months
before mr. Trump suddenly withheld
military aid from Ukraine the focus of
the impeachment inquiry not exactly sure
what the Ambassador is doing here today
but Democrats say her removal opened the
door for someone else hi I'm Gordon
Sandlin a Trump donor an EU ambassador
who urged the Ukrainians to look into
the president's campaign rival Joe Biden
and the 2016 election and in closed-door
testimony late Friday State Department
official David Holmes testified that he
heard sunland talking to President Trump
on the phone he heard mr. Trump a
Sandlin if Ukrainian president Solinsky
was going to quote do the investigation
Sandlin replied he's gonna do it and
will do anything you ask him to do now
Gordon Sumlin will be testifying
publicly next week
sure all right Ben thank you